[Musique]
les états unis et la corée du nord
s'affrontent depuis le début de la
guerre de corée en 1950 la corée du nord
allié de l'union soviétique a envahi la
corée du sud allié des américains
[Musique]
le conflit dure trois ans et fait près
de 3 millions de victimes
depuis malgré un armistice les tensions
demeurent
les etats unis maintiennent des milliers
de soldats en corée du sud au début des
années 90 la corée du nord est devenue
le pays le plus fermé du monde avec
comme seul allié la chine
nous payons de table what you say la
famine des milliers de nord coréens
meurent de faim les etats unis sont
prêts à accorder une aide économique
mais en retour le régime communiste doit
suspendre son programme nucléaire qu'ils
développent en secret c'est le début
d'un processus de rapprochement qui va
durer six ans mais il n'y aura pas de
traiter la dictature de la famille kim
se sent menacé par les troupes
américaines en corée du sud
elle veut la bombe atomique en janvier
2006 les crânes américaine se confirme
pyonyang réussi son premier essai
nucléaire d'autres négociations ont lieu
mais la corée du nord refuse de mettre
fin à son programme d'armement
c'est une question de survie pour un
régime aux abois
on
[Musique]
la corée du nord poursuit donc ses
essais nucléaires il y en aura six au
total il y aura aussi des tests de
missiles balistiques dont certains sont
lancés au dessus du japon
en 2017 d'un match en arrive au pouvoir
c'est le début d'un nouveau cycle de
tensions le président tom promet le feu
et la colère ils menacent de détruire
carrément à la corée du nord kim jong-un
le nargue avec des missiles balistiques
qui pourraient atteindre les états unis
mais au moment où le spectre d'une
guerre se dessine le nord tend la main
au sud les athlètes nord-coréen
participent aux jeux olympiques de
pyongyang et les présidents des deux
corées se rencontrent sur la ligne
d'armistice en quelques semaines
tout bascule le monde est stupéfait
quand donald trump accepte de rencontrer
kim jong-un celui qu'il traitait de
bouffon et de rocket man ce sommet de
singapour était inimaginable il ya
quelques mois mais va-t-il tenir ses
promesses avec deux hommes imprévisible
comme donald trump et kim jong-un
tout est possible
[Musique]